almost everything you do in life you're  gonna hit plateaus you know have to  battle  isn't hitting those plateaus plateaus  are inevitable like working out I used  to work out to impress girls I don't  work out today to impress girls my  desire to work out today is to be able  to have energy enough to run the  businesses and to be able to wrestle  with my four kids and spend time and  have time with my wife you know and stay  healthy I want to be able to live a good  amount of time to you know witness these  things so the evolution of working out  changes the evolution of marriage  changes the evolution of health and  eating changes the evolution of  consuming content changes I don't read  books I read today that I did 20 years  ago just because somebody recommended it  if you send me a book 15 years ago I  would read it I don't read a book today  if you send it to me I read books I want  to read today I don't read books because  you tell me to read the